Sunny host from The View who insists
that most Americans are racist there are
absolutely racist people in this country
it is not the vast majority of people in
this country and I feel like well FBI
director said white supremacy is the
biggest threat to our country today well
that still doesn't mean that that's the
vast majority of people are I just don't
believe that in my dayto day life that
the people that you're encountering
Harbor racist viewpoints I do think that
this division that were you look like me
you would believe differently but you
know what alisten the woman the woman
just to understand are we saying do we
think the vast majority of Americans are
racist that's what I'm trying to help me
understand I think that there is a
significant portion um that are racist
and you can't dismiss my lived
experience and I never would I I would
never and by racist of course Sunny
hustin does not mean people attacking
whites for the color of their skin by
law or by culture no no no it can't be
that because you can't be racist against
white people no no it's got to be racism
against black people and to a much
lesser degree every other race